Françoise de ce que vous avez entendu de
Monsieur Trudeau là au cours des
dernières minutes est-ce que vous
trouvez qu'il joue bien son rôle de
premier ministre dans les circonstances
je pense que il démontre moi ce qui me
fascine en rajoute un petit peu à ce que
Michel nous disait tantôt ce qui te
fascinant c'est de voir la solidarité
québécoise les gens qui sont
accueillants qui offrent leur place mais
je voulais rajouter la solidarité pas
canadienne
interprovincial lorsqu'on a une province
est en difficulté le Québec répond quand
c'est le Québec d'autres provinces des
fois les discours politiques nous
laissent croire que tout le monde est à
plutôt tiré mais dans les moments comme
ceux qui ont envie présentement au
Québec on sent cette solidarité puis pas
juste à l'intérieur du Canada quand
c'est rendu que des pays comme la France
l'Australie l'Afrique du Sud en voie de
l'aide c'est bon signe et ça je pense
que c'était de bonne aloi que le premier
ministre canadien le souligne en même
temps ben si certains qu'on aura
beaucoup de de réflexion à avoir de
prendre un peu de recul on peut pas
juste dire et c'est la faute au
changement climatique faut faut régler
la crise des changements climatiques
puis comme si ça va régler tous ces
drames là moi je pense à des petits des
petits kids qui sont nés dans les 5
dernières années dans mon coin de pays
moi en outai qui ont vécu je sais pas
deux tornades une inondation une
pandémie maintenant des feux de forêt
parce que la fumée s'en vient jusqu'ici
pour se fait dire de rester à
l'intérieur de nos maisons de porter des
masques quel monde de fou alors il va
falloir que nos politiciens arrêtent
peut-être de faire un peu de politique
avec tout ça parce que on parle de
sécurité on parle de de la vie des gens
il faut trouver des moyens à long terme
alors je pense qu'il va falloir avoir
une vision peut-être un petit peu plus
large que des phrases toutes faites qui
donnent l'impression que si on règle un
règle toute parce que ça va prendre
l'équipement ça va prendre si est-ce
qu'on à dépenser puis à taxer le budget
puis enlever peut-être quelque chose
ailleurs pour mettre plus d'argent pour
avoir ces avions citerne pour avoir plus
de formation de pompiers alors c'est des
discussions sérieuses qui devront être
faites sérieusement tout le monde
ensemble ça de l'air de toucher pas mal
partout à travers le pays Jean-François
la peut-être la nouvelle du jour ça va
être sur les avions les pilotes là qui
doivent prendre du repos donc ils
pourront pas commettre les incendies ou
quoi des prochains jours en fait à court
terme ils sont capables de maintenir la
cadence mais à moyen terme il va falloir
un moment donné qui se repose pour pas
dépasser leurs heures de vol sur les
effectifs aussi Dimitri faisait allusion
le fait que au Québec on a 160 160 feux
puis qu'on a combat seulement une
quarantaine est-ce que il y a moyen de
faire les choses différemment est-ce
qu'on devrait avoir plus de monde en
même temps il y a une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre puis la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre elle touche tous les secteurs
de l'économie donc est-ce que ça vous
surprend dans le fond c'est la question
est-ce que ça vous surprend l'état des
lieux des effectifs au gouvernement du
Québec en ce moment Jean-François
c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas en avant de la
vague on est derrière la vague la vague
la vague d'incendie l'important en ce
moment c'est
c'est de maximiser évidemment tout ce
qu'on a de coopérer au maximum et je
pense que là dessus pour l'instant le
bilan qu'on peut en tirer c'est que tout
le monde fait le maximum y compris entre
les provinces et de façon internationale
et d'ailleurs quand on voit les gens
venir d'aussi loin que l'Afrique du Sud
on sait qu'il arrive souvent que nos
propres pompiers ou nos réparateurs nos
moteurs de ligne etc nos techniciens
Hydro-Québec sont toujours très prends à
aller aider à l'extérieur ce sont des
ascenseurs qui partent qui reviennent ou
des avions qui reviennent il y a aucun
doute que dans les années qui viennent
il va avoir une montée en force de la
préparation y compris de l'équipement
sur la question des canadaires je
m'attendais pas à ce que le premier
ministre aujourd'hui
un renforcement de la capacité de
production mais il est certain enfin
vraiment responsable frais ce que ce
qu'on a fait pendant la pandémie par
exemple on a réussi en quelques mois à
augmenter la capacité de production des
vaccins de façon extraordinairement
rapide aux États-Unis ils ont utilisé la
loi américaine qui permet de
réquétitionner comme entendre guère pour
augmenter la production évidemment ils
ont rien à signalisé ils ont simplement
rendu disponible des fonds pour
augmenter la production moi je
m'attendrai à ce qu'il y a un plan
canadien pour faire en sorte que la
compagnie Viking triple la grandeur de
son usine pour produire énormément de
Canada puis là s'il y a quelque chose
dont on est certain qu'on va tous les
vendre c'est bien des canadaires au
cours des 10-15 40 prochaines années et
donc pas quasiment pas de limite à la
production je serai pas surpris que
d'autres compagnies d'aviation dans le
monde décident contraire ou les autres
de produire leur propre version de ces
avions dans la nécessité n'est pas n'est
pas démontré pour la suite alors ça si
on veut à la fois pouvoir avoir notre
propre flotte à la hauteur de nos
besoins il faut agir tout de suite et il
y a pas de doute que il y a un marché à
prendre aussi c'est bizarre de dire ça
mais effectivement on puisque c'est nous
qui l'avons inventé ce serait une bonne
chose qu'on soit parmi les premiers
producteurs sur la pénurie mais neuve il
y a toujours des décisions stratégiques
je veux dire d'ailleurs la stratégie du
gouvernement québécois c'est de
prioriser les infirmières les
travailleurs de la construction et un
certain nombre de trucs stratégiques
mais là c'est clair que cette liste là
il va falloir rajouter de prioriser la
formation des équipes d'intervention
dans les cas de sinistre sinistre
inondations sinistre feu est-ce que il
va y avoir au sein de l'armée canadienne
une unité qui est qui devrait s'occuper
de ça ça serait pas une mauvaise idée
mais je vais vous dire quelque chose
aussi c'est que le Canada a débloqué
l'an dernier 19 milliards de dollars
pour acheter des F35 peut-être qu'on
pourra prendre un ou deux pour acheter
des Canadiens un ou deux milliards ça
serait un bon investissement Dimitri il
dit non ok Dimitri et je vais vous dire
peut-être
avec citerne avec des bandeaux
et je vais vous dire pourquoi je dis non
on est toujours réactif pandémie arrive
pas capable de produire des vaccins post
pandémie oh on a besoin d'usines pour la
fabrication de vaccins nous avions qui
datent depuis je vais exagérer la
deuxième guerre mondiale ah ils peuvent
plus voler là on achète des avions nos
sous-marins ils font que flotter il peut
pas aller sous l'eau sous l'eau si on
doit arrêter d'être réactif je sais pas
si quelqu'un tu connais mais au
gouvernement mais après la Russie notre
territoire et le deuxième plus vaste
dans le monde donc présentement il y a
une cellule de crise une cellule de
crise qui j'espère comme à notre époque
et mener par des gens qui posent
beaucoup de questions et qui défient
ceux qui disent par exemple en 50 heures
ils peuvent plus voler ben est-ce qu'on
peut prendre un pilote de notre avion
puis
l'utiliser pour les avions les avions
ces termes il faut être en mode
formation et de ne pas nécessairement
accepter après est-ce qu'on peut faire
52 heures est-ce qu'on peut faire moins
de repos qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec
les citrons que nous avons présentement
parce que c'est ça la réalité on est mal
préparé on est tellement mal préparé et
je ne blâme pas c'est pas sur le plan
politique là si c'est pas juste un
Trudeau ou Steven Harper c'est
collectivement on attend le désastre et
ensuite on est en mode réactif et je
vous gâche une chose Sébastien
les feux de forêt seront éteints on va
voir si ça va être mauvais été ou un bel
été et les gens vont dire on se croise
les doigts que ça ne surviendra pas
encore une fois dans un an ou deux ans
c'est là où il faut avoir les bonnes
priorités parce que l'argent ne pousse
pas sur des arbres des priorités
préventives mais aussi une fois la crise
arrivée on est là présentement en train
de dire les avions citerne Canada que le
Canada envoya à travers le monde pour
aider les autres pays on en fera
fabrique plus bombardière était son
programme l'ont vendu un petit
entreprises peuvent être bâtir 10 avions
par année et tous les autres pays sont
en avant de nous
2027 on attend jusqu'en 2027 en son tour
en se tournant les pouces donc est-ce
qu'on peut anticiper un petit peu puis
de dire il faut avoir des priorités où
on anticipe les enjeux mais là la
cellule de crise qui je suis certain
existe leur première priorité parce que
c'est une cellule de crise sans doute
menée par le bureau du premier ministre
même chose qu'on avait fait par exemple
quand on évacuait les Canadiens de la
Tunisie lors de la crise dans le
Moyen-Orient c'est de défier chaque
personne qui dit ce n'est pas possible
ok parce que c'est impossible n'est pas
français voilà il faut pouvoir vouloir
faire les choses
c'est tellement important ce que dit
Dimitri parce que on réagit trop là on a
eu des ouragans on a eu des inondations
on a des feux on a eu du verglas tout ça
à l'intérieur de ces changements
climatiques et on ne sent pas là les
deux premiers ministres monsieur Trudeau
hier je crois monsieur Legault dise on
aura des questions à se poser des
petites nouvelles pour toutes nos autres
il y a des grosses questions à se poser
mais des questions où on va pouvoir se
faire un plan d'adaptation c'est pas
juste des mots là en ce moment on entend
que des mots mais ça doit se traduire
par des décisions des actions et oui ça
va orienter nos budgets et oui ça va
changer nos modes de vie à nous comme
citoyens première chose il va falloir
qu'on accepte comme disait Françoise que
nos budgets seront plus tout à fait les
sources de dépenses là seront plus tout
à fait les mêmes il va falloir que
collectivement
de définissent ces priorités là et je
termine en disant il va falloir aussi
que les gouvernements se
écoute la science écoute les
scientifiques et ce collent aux aspects
scientifiques qui prévoit mais qui donne
des solutions dans tous les secteurs
d'activité que ça soit l'aménagement des
territoires la construction que ce soit
les comment investir dans les transports
que ce soit la façon de protéger nos
infrastructures mais je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'on soit beaucoup plus
proactif et qu'on aille plus rapidement
et et ça passe par nous tous il va
falloir que ça fasse un peu mal
malheureusement parce que là on écoute
les discours puis là on est tous oui on
a tous les belles paroles on pense qu'on
a tous les bonnes solutions mais c'est
un peu pas dans ma cour il faut pas que
ça touche la façon dont je vis mais
quand ça va toucher notre façon de vivre
et c'est là où les gouvernements doivent
exercer le leaders et un leadership fort
à ces événements-là
qui ont été évacués salitouche
parce qu'ils ont déjà vécu leur maison
Françoise un petit clin d'oeil à vous
juste pour terminer la discussion il y a
vous nous parliez de Maxime Bernier qui
disait que c'était des terroristes de
école terroristes écologique qui avait
mis le feu
dans certains foyers Steven gilbault lui
a répondu aujourd'hui et belle réplique
et écouter monsieur Guilbaud j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il prend du pic
politique là il a mis son veston de
politicien aujourd'hui on l'écoute
je dirais pas que Monsieur berniole
monopole là-dessus on envoie des gens
comme ça du côté du Parti conservateur
du Canada qui se lève en chambre de
temps en temps pour nier l'existence
même des changements climatiques c'est
quand même incroyable que ce bonhomme là
a été ministre des Affaires étrangères
sur un gouvernement conservateur je
pense que c'est en dit long sur le
gouvernement conservateur et la priorité
qu'il donne à des dossiers comme celui
des changements climatiques
de ce que monsieur Bernier dit pour
attaquer les conservateurs des
conservateurs exactement
j'ai trouvé que c'est j'ai trouvé que
c'était génial comme réplique parce que
bon il y a il y a dénigrer un petit peu
l'individu avec raison il y aurait de
lui en disant et ça se peut tu puis dire
qu'il a été ministre des Affaires
étrangères conservateurs alors là il
attaque aussi le parti conserve et ça a
déjà fait partie de votre gangs et en
plus ben ça s'inscrit un peu dans la
mouvance conservatrice parce que des
fois on a des députés qui viennent à la
Chambre des communes nous faire des
petits discours anti changement
climatique alors
effectivement là il y a joué Yumi son
chapeau de policiers n'ont pas d'activer
est-ce que ça faisait partie des bonnes
ou des mauvaises nominations de Monsieur
bonne question j'arrive à répondre à
votre question mais d'abord je vais
répondre à la question de Françoise
aujourd'hui je m'identifie comme
Françoise donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé à parler
donc
honnêtement c'est probablement la
première fois et peut-être la dernière
fois que je vais être entièrement en
accord avec Monsieur Guilbaud comment ça
se fait que ce gars-là était ministre
des Affaires étrangères du Canada mais
c'est ça
recommandé je pense
je me souviens pas je me souviens pas je
me souviens pas il faut mais retire tes
paroles sinon je t'amène en cours
[Musique]
sincèrement Maxime Bernier il a eu sa
réponse des bosserons il se croyait le
roi des bosserons puis les bosserons lui
a dit non on veut pas de toi tu n'es
certainement pas à l'auteur et à l'image
de ton père qu'il est Beaucerons avec
élu non seulement comme conservateur
mais aussi comme indépendant donc
écoutez je pense que monsieur Bernier
est en train de de faire sa dernière
tentative
de de de
stupidité qui peut dire pour
l'élection partielle où il se présente
dans un comté où je crois selon ce que
j'entends il va avoir 20 moins que 20%.
donc peut-être espérons ce sont des
derniers chapitre puis là il peut aller
faire quelque chose pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI